5 25 on your Wednesday morning was
driving you crazy well the Regional
Transportation Commission encourages you
to let them know if you got a hinky
traffic signal on your commute
well viewer Susan writes the left turn
signal from eastbound Craig to
Northbound Clayton sometimes doesn't
kick in often going through three Cycles
before giving the turn arrow backing up
traffic causing a dangerous situation
when cars pull out of the turn lane to
go through the main light no particular
time of day I've been stuck morning noon
and evening
Susan I've let the RTC traffic signal
folks know about your concern they're
looking into it there is a cool phone
number to know though because with the
hundreds of signals under their watch 24
7 they want you to give them a heads up
if any particular light needs to be
looked at so here's the number
702-901-8400 now we mentioned this in a
recent driving you crazy report but we
know not everybody watches the news all
the time and don't worry if you don't
have time to write down this number it's
in the online version of this story when
you visit 8newsnow.com click traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down the phone and
join the driving you crazy conversation
it's traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com